rapido we're talking about octane and
apex legends in this guide and how to
best use him Erik what's the quick
rundown on octane well octane being the
adrenaline junkie wants to go fast right
so he is a great flanker he's great for
scouting he can either you know be in
the front or even in the rear just kind
of like making sure everything's all you
know hunky-dory but mainly it's about
his tactical still yeah his tactical
still moved 30% faster for six seconds
however it costs health about 10% of
your health yeah it's got a super quick
cool down it gives you the ability to as
you mentioned go 30% faster right so you
can get into fights whenever you want
you can get away whenever you want so
you know sometimes you're ahead of your
team and you're like oh crap that's an
enemy team right in front of me and they
start either maybe shooting you or
something but you can decide like hey I
better pop my stem and get away get back
to my teammates right or you know if you
are engaged in combat with another team
and maybe they're like not you know like
not super far away or if they're far
away you can kind of tell your team like
hey I'm gonna do a big wraparound play
because you have the mobility to do so
right and something to be said about
this ability is that obviously everyone
wants the purple armor once the high
tier but with octane what armor type you
have will kind of be the gauge of how
often you can use your stem because
obviously you're losing health so if you
have purple armor you can use your stem
far more often comfortably right because
you have that protection if you don't
have any armor you know you maybe want
to use it once or twice with that in
mind I find octane to be far better at
close range I think you know you should
be not focusing so much on picking up
sniper rifles I think shotguns for sure
SMGs are all great because it's kind of
the methodology with octane is that
you're getting into a fight you're
getting into people's faces quickly and
then you're bouncing out I'll up tracer
from overwatch you're not you're not
really hanging around because you're
kind of so vulnerable as you have just
lost 10% your health it's better to be
always on the move with octane then I
mean because you are skimming and
because you you know you're always on
the move right definitely make sure to
load up on syringes med packs
so that you can compensate for the help
loss obviously now we are gonna talk
about his passive Swift men soon but
definitely want to make sure you have
those on the ready the other thing I
would say about octane is with interior
locations like bunker with like long
hallways your stem isn't as clutch the
beauty of the stem is that you can get
out and behind obstacles so like open
areas with like rock formations are all
great I guess that would be something to
keep in mind is that you know your stem
doesn't work as well inside buildings
also fun fact you can't actually kill
yourself with stem right like I don't
know what youth case you'd be it I guess
yeah I guess if you're really hurt and
you had to run away you could keep
stemming it won't actually like knock
you which is good and steam is also good
just to get out of the circle right get
away from the circle or get through a
circle
moving on to passive swift mend is
probably the coolest part about octane
and that you automatically restore
health over time when you're not in
combat I think there's like a
five-second delay where once you are not
being hit it takes about five seconds
for Swift men to take into effect where
you get one HP per two seconds maybe I
haven't played the character enough but
I don't feel it's as good as it needs to
be but maybe it is the way it is because
it would be too overpowered otherwise if
you stand like twice I don't even know
if you're getting the first stand back
in that time but as you had mentioned
earlier armor is pretty key and you know
maybe you're just making sure your
armors topped off and then when you can
then you top off your HP for sure I mean
I think it really doubles down on on the
fact that you need to be you need to be
moving always you need to be in and out
of firefights not so much like Oh like
present in a firefight but the other
part about octane is that I would say
you know you're prioritizing shields if
you know the perfect situation you have
that purple armor focus on getting your
shields fixed first and if your health
is substantially low then yes you know
pop some syringes or med kits
moving on to the ultimate launch pad
deploy a jump pad that catapults
teammates and yourself through the air
pretty awesome way to start a fight I
would say what do you think about it
yeah I think there's a lot of use cases
for it and the best use case I've seen
or done myself is using it just to get
tactical high ground or you know maybe
someone's fighting in you know in or on
top of a building that you want to get
access to that's like a pretty good use
of launch pad like you can use the
launch pad to gain a tactical advantage
or to you know hop over stuff right it's
like the answer to area-denial someone's
even throwing down like thermite
grenades you can get over that I think
it's a pretty neat way to catch someone
off their guard especially when the
cooldown is so short like you should not
hesitate to throw that thing there have
been plenty of times where I've just
taken someone by surprise because
they're not expecting me to be
vertically above and over them again
like like it's it's a great way to flank
someone and get right behind them but
yeah it has some other like kind of
funny or fun use cases you can throw
grenades off of it you can throw
thermite off of it you can kind of throw
a mirage decoy off of it it in some
cases he looks like he leaves a
silhouette in the air and disappears
gibraltars shield maybe you throw that
and kind of use that as cover like
that's in front of you potentially you
know if you just want to put it down
tactically I'm not sure how all that's
gonna work out I just know that you can
use it for that yeah like it's got some
creative use for sure you can throw a
beneath you and jump on it like a
trampoline you can throw it beneath your
teammates if their looting legendary
death boxes and jettison them away so
you can loot but most importantly I
think the beauty of the launch pad for
sure is getting on top and getting the
high ground getting on rooftops getting
on like market right ASAP yeah and I
think if there's a one more thing to add
I guess is that if you're a NOC team and
you see a trap you can actually use that
as well and you know maybe the t the
other enemy team is fighting another
team maybe you use that to bounce back
to you know the octane that's maybe
behind you or like just a teammate
behind you so you can get a revive off
well if you're looking for more apex
legend guides we got videos just like
this one on all of the other legends so
check them out
as always thanks for watching